[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
I'm Pittsburgh uncensored tonight Harry
and Megan say Paparazzi photographers
subjected them to a near catastrophic
their words to our their claim car chase
in New York for their story not for the
first time is already unraveling we'll
have the latest also tonight the
shocking subway killing was bitterly
divided America ex-marine placed a
homeless black man in a deadly Chokehold
on the subway so why are so many people
not calling him a hero
[Music]
we have breaking news tonight Prince
Harry his wife Megan and her mother
Doria Ragland were in New York last
night for the women of vision Awards
Megan was honored for her lifelong
advocacy for equality
we'll come to that later and regardless
of what you think about that and I have
my views all the two of them in general
it's clear that they were involved in an
incident last night that caused them
distress
but just how much went down last night
and what exactly happened is now
becoming a contentious issue the couple
say they were involved in a quote near
catastrophic close quotes to our car
chase at the hands of Paparazzi in
Manhattan from 10 o'clock to midnight
sources close to them so they were
followed by half a dozen blacked out
Vehicles which mounted Pavements and
Skip red lights tonight the times
reports are Harry told friends it's the
closest he's ever felt to understanding
what happened to his mother Princess
Diana a couple for the spokesman
especially a couple said last night the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex and Miss
Ragland were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase at the hands of a
ring of Highly aggressive Paparazzi this
Relentless Pursuit Relentless Pursuit
lasting two hours resulted in multiple
new collisions involving other drivers
on the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers while being a public figure
comes with a level of interest from the
public it should never come at the cost
of anyone's safety but by contrast the
New York Police Department statement was
well it was singularly less dramatic on
Wednesday evening they said May 16th the
NYPD assisted the private security team
protecting the Duke and Duchess of
Sussex there were numerous photographers
that made their transport challenging
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex arrived
at their destination and there were no
reporting collisions summonses injuries
or or arrests in that regard
another taxi driver who at one stage
transported the couple for about 10
minutes has now told the Washington Post
he wouldn't call the incident a Chase
and said he felt safe during the ride
Recollections as the late Queen once
said appear to be very well joining me
now a journalist at North for Patron and
white Princess Diana's former Royal
Protection Officer Ken wolf talk to you
if you were all editor Sarah Houston an
editorial director of the politics
column in New York Post Emily Smith over
a new or welcome to you a stellar panel
all right Sarah let's what do we know I
mean what we knew was the first thing we
knew was the statement from the sussexes
very dramatic well I took a sharp intake
of breath when I saw that there was a
near catastrophic car chase and I think
many people will have done last night
they were in New York for a very well
publicized event the women of vision
Awards which Megan was presented with an
award they left we've seen footage of
them leaving they got into a black SUV
at around 10 o'clock last night
apparently they were on just to be clear
about the geography they were on 57th
Street in Midtown Manhattan yeah and
they were traveling to a private
residence on the Upper East Side now at
that time of night I've lived on the
upper east side of Manhattan for years
uh that's a that's a 5-10 minute Journey
so what is baffling me is how this ends
up taking two hours what wait what's
that it's just good they drove up and
down FDR for an hour and a quarter
apparently trying to evade the
photographers they were staying at an
address on the Upper East Side that had
been lent to them by friends they didn't
want them to know and my question now is
who who were they staying with and
didn't want us to know where they were
so trying to evade those photographers
they then ended up at a police station
on the night the 19th Precinct where
they changed vehicles and they got into
a taxi and as you said the taxi driver
who picked them up quite extraordinary
said he was hailed and asked do you want
a fair and he took them for 10 minutes
he said they seemed scared he said there
were two cars in Pursuit at that stage
he didn't it was a Chase and uh weirdly
he goes off for 10 minutes over a few
blocks and then he comes back to where
he picked them up and then we don't
really know
they got somewhere safely at the end of
all this they did so we've got a map
this is a map of uh of Manhattan there
and you see the the southern tip of
Central Park is pretty much where they
were at this uh this event
getting an award and then they kind of
zigzag up and down for the next two
hours for reasons that completely baffle
me because I don't know why you would do
that I mean they've got a security team
just go where you're going you're there
in five ten minutes all right you're
determined to get in here I am
determined because I think it is utter I
also lived in New York in the Upper East
Side and I've spoken to 20 New Yorkers
and they're laughing their heads off it
is impossible to have a two-hour
high-speed car chase in New York the
traffic is gridlocked it's impossible to
get a vehicle to go more than nine miles
an hour it's also impossible for an
alleged Paparazzi blacked out car to
drive on the pavement without being
stopped arrested or noticed the weird
thing is that there are no witnesses to
this well I would put one caveat in here
is that Harry was seen filming out of
the car so we're probably going to get
wait wait a minute but there are no
witnesses to what he's describing as a
two-hour we know the police but the
police version is not as dramatic no the
police the police are saying there are
no reports uh of collisions no one was
arrested if it was as Harry said with
two or three more Paparazzi cars
illegally driving on the sidewalk they
would have been around that would be a
crime it's okay exactly can I mean just
off the top
since the death of his mother and I
completely understand his pathological
hatred of Paparazzi after what happened
to his mum I get it okay I'm not gonna
question his right to feel that way
about Paparazzi generally it's about
what really went on though last night
and bearing in mind the context of his
court case here at the moment to try and
get better protection when he comes over
here with his family at the taxpayer
expense there are cynics out there
they've already been saying it on social
media is this just him over egging an
incident which happens probably most
nights of the week in Manhattan with
celebrities to try and get what he wants
over here well I think that may be the
case here's I mean but what I'm what I'm
confused with is this sort of near
catastrophic yeah I mean to me what I
see is is quite normal for that sort of
event I mean here he is you know a major
a-lister whatever it is in New York
being pursued by the paparazzi which is
which is normal I think what what what
what I have and it has to be said legal
so under the First Amendment they're
allowed to do this now the question is
if the way they were driving was illegal
that's a different issue but the police
have made clear no arrests
The Point again Ken unlike here the laws
got pretty well tightened after what
happened with Diana you couldn't do this
in this country legally but you can in
New York well no you can't drive on the
pavement no no no I'm claiming that I
understand that but I'm saying that yeah
but I think the way she pursues
celebrities as Paparazzi in New York is
a legal thing to be doing yeah but but
Harry and Megan must have expected this
to happen I mean you know he's got this
sort of private security uh business or
company whatever now who clearly this is
something new to them because they from
what I observed they were unable to deal
with this problem now you know in the UK
I mean for many years when I worked with
them in a taxi
what's an interesting thing but I mean
what security team in the world but the
guys what's the fifth in line to the
throne of England in a random Yellow Cab
with his wife and his and his
mother-in-law and off they go I mean I
found that well surely this is this is
you wouldn't put Tom Hanks in a Yellow
Cab I wouldn't get one but then why why
then did they put him in a taxi it's
obvious to me that the the the security
company looking after him there really
not don't have the experience to deal
with someone with him now you know he
knows more than anybody else you know
the role of the paparazzi he know that
that they will pursue him and they know
that you know they are what I will say
is a nuisance Factor worse look the
paparazzi don't kill people you know I'm
not going to say that you know we know
what the Judgment was in in the case of
Diana's inquest you know where the Scott
Baker said that the she died as a result
of a driver over the drink Drive limit
and a contributive factor of the
pursuing Paparazzi but they'd actually
don't kill people look I could be very
careful to see here but you know all the
years that I looked after don't I know
there was a royal family never once did
we find a problem with the paparazzi yes
they're a nuisance Factor but they have
to be dealt well what happened here is
they didn't get dealt with it but to be
bringing Emily just quickly here Emily I
think the issue is in in New York the
paparazzi can be pretty full-on I've
seen them they've done it to me right
which I was actually quite pleased about
um but you know you go to La you go to
New York or even some other cities in
America they can be much more aggressive
than anything you get over here now
um and that's what made me chuckle when
I heard they were going leaving the
Dreadful intrusive media in the UK to go
to Hollywood and go to New York all the
time because it's like you trust me if
you think you're going to get an easier
time there for the media forget it
you're not you're not and uh you know
what's happening today is their story is
just completely unraveling you know the
police are now saying it wasn't two
hours it was an hour and they drove
around New York and you know peers that
you know you can walk faster than you
can drive around New York at that time
of night
um and why on Earth did they could put
them in a Yellow Cab
um it's just it's just beyond belief I
mean no security team would put them in
a Yellow Cab and also we know that
they've got a lot of um you know friends
in hotels in New York I mean they could
have just driven to the Carlisle or
walked in the front entrance and said
can we stay here for an hour or whatever
and then go when the paps had left
that's what I know I don't understand
they could have gone anywhere like that
yeah they stayed at the Carlisle many
times and they could have just gone
there been completely safe until it all
died down but for some this is why I'm
slightly cynical I mean Sarah I am
slightly cynical about the motives of
all this and the timing just given the
fact that he's over here waging a legal
battle to get better protection when he
comes this of course is the in a way the
perfect story that he could say there
you go
um now I would again the caveat we
haven't seen any footage and Harry we
know was taking some as were his
security people maybe he will produce
footage which looks terrifying we don't
know so there's a caveat there yes there
is and and I suppose it depends whose
eyes you're looking at this through and
he is looking at this Through The Eyes
of someone who has said repeatedly he
fears history is going to repeat itself
he's very protective over his wife we
know he's very protective over his
security but you're right to raise the
backdrop of this he has multiple court
cases going through on press intrusion
but also on his security fighting the
home office to get met police protection
when he's over here my understanding is
when you're in New York you can hire
NYPD officers to protect you when
they're off duty which is effectively
what he's looking for over here but it
didn't work last night did it no it
didn't it didn't work last night and
Emily what is the reaction of Americans
to this because Harry and Megan are now
basically they're celebrities all
celebrities that go to New York I've
seen it they all get the same treatment
it's not like they're getting anything
different to people like Beyonce and the
other public event
event they were they were photography
we'd expect to have photographers there
and they would have expected to have
been followed but you know
it's driven at the speed limit it and
gone to their destination and posed up
before they went in and then that was
that
um but there's some theories emerging
um you know one is of course what you
said is there there were their battle to
get tighter security to protect them and
their family which you know I can
understand why there was a stalker
arrested outside their house in
Montecito today
um but also it has to be said and this
is my theory and I I haven't proven it
yet that they you know they've got this
100 million dollar deal with Netflix
um and they've just produced that
documentary which you know we've all
opined on and they haven't actually
managed to come up with any other shows
so you know right there whatever Harry
filmed last night will be his next next
Netflix Netflix special
I'm afraid like a lot of people I am
very very cynical about everything these
two do I'm also cynical about the way
they describe things that happen to them
the truth is they exaggerate if not
lacks about almost everything yeah
because they they issued a statement in
which they were specific about six black
tap Paparazzi cars driving on the
sidewalk of New York pursuing them for
two hours causing near catastrophic
multiple crashes now it turns out that
if there was an incident it was so minor
compared to this and there were not six
well I don't think we I don't think we'd
know exactly well the nyp if NYPD didn't
make any arrests so they clearly didn't
see anything which constituted security
detail has spoken yeah has said he'd
never experienced anything like it and
it could have been my responsibility
this is the same well no it's the same a
is on the payroll but secondly they're
the security detail that put their three
very prized charges into a random yellow
black uh Yellow Cab right I'm sorry but
the NYPD though on board with that
because that was taking place I just
thought that's the part of the story I
don't get and apparently the yellow cat
went around the timings and and then
brought them back where he bit them up
something illegal or dangerous they
would have let's not talk over each
other yeah but I think I think what this
this shows actually is the the
ineffectiveness of the security that is
actually he's employed and we mentioned
there the NYPD I know from my own
experience that if there was a potential
problem of being you know attacked by
the president all that you do is speak
the NYPD or any police and that that
advice would be forthcoming yeah but I
mean this is the problem and to put
somebody in a Yellow Taxi is just sort
of against all security ideas and that's
where maybe he has a case but coming
back to here in the UK the government
and and have been quite quite adamant
yeah that he is not eligible for for
security what they've done in the past
there's no reason why the British taxes
but they will provide him with a liaison
within broader protection to make it
work okay and that's all that needs to
be done I've got to leave it there with
uh this Stellar pack thank you all very
much indeed I'm saying to the next Harry
and Megan we're in New York of their own
volition of course attending an awards
Gala at which the entire point was to be
the center of media attention did that
confuse relationship with privacy play a
role in the subsequent drama or debate
that
[Music]
foreign
exclusive because we are joined by the
man who was the taxi driver in this well
the part of this wild car chase with the
Duke and Duchess of Sussex uh Sunny
Singh was driving his Yellow Cab last
night and picked him up and went off for
10 minutes and then brought them back it
seems joins me now live from New York Mr
Singh thank you very much indeed for
joining me
how you doing can you tell me exactly
what happened last night
uh so I was crossing on 67th Street
going going West on 67 and by the
precinct there was security standing
there they held me and they say you need
it are you empty I said yes and uh like
they told me to pull aside as I pulled
to the side Prince Harry and his wife
and another lady jumped into my cab and
they seemed very nervous and uh as we
went a block we were blocked by a trash
truck and then all of a sudden Paparazzi
just came out of nowhere and just
flashes just went off how many Paparazzi
would you say there were when when you
had them in your house six six that I
seen and there were about two cars
following us uh as we as the trash cup a
trash truck moved and there was two cars
falling up and where did they want to go
well they were just about to say the
location where they were gonna go but
then the paparazzis came and the
security guard said Hey listen just
circle back to the precinct so they had
a security guard in the cab as well
in the cab yeah okay you see him in one
of the pictures he's sitting next to me
were you surprised that they were in
your cab
uh you know not so much you know we get
celebrities in the city all the time you
know so not so much
we know that the paparazzi you don't
know who you get right you don't know
who you're gonna pick up in New York
right so right and that's true but I
mean in your experience was the
paparazzi attention any more or less
than it would be for other major
celebrities
crazy with the camera and how would you
just every time every yeah go ahead how
would you describe how Harry and Megan
were about this
they were nervous they were nervous you
could see the look on their face
did they talk to you at all directly
ah no not as much I mean when they were
exiting they say what's your name and I
said sunny and uh that's like have a
good night and then stay exited and then
they went back into the SUV again
it's being categorized that there was a
two-hour wild car chase through the
streets of New York but was it was the
time that must have been that must have
happened before me
when you were there
uh not when they got into my account we
just went around the block and the car
two cars were tailing us behind us with
the camera and that was it and then and
then you went back to where you'd
actually picked them up yes we went back
to the precinct and then they exited and
they thanked me and I thanked them as
well and then they exited my car did
they remember to pay you sonny
yeah they paid they paid they paid well
they paid well so what's your what's
your view about this you've become the
most famous cab driver in New York
tonight what's your what's your view
about this inside I don't know I don't
know about that there's another one
that's on Tick Tock if he has a bunch of
celebrities in his cat and he usually
got pictures with them
do you think it's uh it's been overblown
this incident or not
you know I don't know what they went
through last night right because I only
had an intersection with them for 15
minutes and they seem very nervous while
they were in my class
okay well Sonny listen I appreciate you
joining me the man at the center of the
of the storm quite literally I
appreciate it thank you very much oh
it's a pleasure talking to you too huh
all the best
okay well joining me now is the Sunday
Times columnist scholar Ivers the
associated to the mirror Kevin McGuire
from New York Fox News contributor and
former bodyguard to Snoop Dogg amongst
others Tyrus well Tyrus let me start
with you you're a you're in New York
you've been a bodyguard to a major star
what do you make of this story
uh man you know what I it sounds much to
do about nothing uh it you know if it
was anybody else it's just that you know
the I don't are they still the royal
family or they still don't want to be a
part of it but want to be a part of it
whatever their issue is they just come
across so thirsty all the time they
drink uh seawater but uh it sounds like
it didn't sound to me like it was that
big of a deal you're in New York it's
going to be crowded uh maybe have your
publicist stop calling Paparazzi and
tell them where you're at uh to get in a
cab to go around the corner and come
back seems silly uh when I was with
Snoop and we were approached by
Paparazzi or he was ever made to feel
nervous I would have got out of the cab
and confronted them and typically make
an example out of one guy with the
camera and the rest would follow so uh
it just seems like it was more staged
than anything else and of course a
two-hour car chase in New York uh where
were you going 15 miles an hour it's New
York you can't move so I think it's
pretty clean it wasn't too out is this
interesting no it was police a police
station at least it looks like half of
that time
sounds like South Park it's got a sequel
all right Charlotte if you have any
sympathy for them I mean you've got to a
bit haven't you given the history behind
this of course Harry's mother died in
such a
car chase and I can sort of imagine if I
was him you'd think it's happening to me
and even if it wasn't that bad your
brain would start to work itself up
probably not to the extent that you'd
then put out a press statement saying
that something like this had happened
you'd hope that some publicists would
get in the way and say hang on let's
talk through maybe let's put this a
little bit further down but in the
moment absolutely I I think I have
sympathy with him but Kevin is tricky
isn't it because as Tara said they've
been spectacularly thirsty for media
attention they've done the Netflix
series with every spitting cough of
their private lives they've done the
book obviously Harry 420 odd pages about
his private life they've sold their
private lives to the highest bidders now
for the last two three years there will
be a lot of people I've seen it all over
social media pretty cynical saying look
if you want to play that game if you
want to work the media that hard for
personal gain for money for profile yeah
then this comes with the territory yeah
it's very different to you know people
who are a very famous but shun publicity
they don't keep going rewards dinners
they don't keep searching for the
Limelight they want there their privacy
um it's very hard to imagine you this
happening in London and I'm not aware if
it ever happened well it wouldn't when
they lived I used to go on Madonna and
in front of I checked an interview I did
with Dinah
um when I was at the mirror it was just
before she died actually a few months
before she died but we I'd had lunch
with her and she told me how the
paparazzi there were certain Rogue
peppers they weren't attached to
newspapers but they were deliberately
upset her by being abusive and when she
reacted emotionally they'd get the
footage they wanted and they would sell
that as Diana's tears over marriage or
whatever and she said please understand
that's what they're doing and I said
okay we're not going to use those
pictures anymore we announced it in the
mirror actually at the time and she
thanked me when I did this interview
from what we had tried to do no
unfortunately you can't control the
world's Paparazzi uh many of them are
good hard-working decent people I'm work
with a lot of them over the years and
some are complete Rogues so we don't
really know yet but you know it may be
last night was a pretty chastening
experience yes the question then becomes
how much of that do you bring on
yourself yeah and uh you know I I agree
the sympathy for in the way his mother
died and he said every time he sees a
flash or hears the click of a camera he
goes back and he's clearly a troubled
young man and you could say yep they
they've made themselves celebs so you're
going to get attention they want to
conceal where and who they're staying
with why do they want to do that but I
also understand why some of the people
would want to know where and who they
are staying with but that wouldn't
excuse anything
you've got a complete privacy yeah you
know we had the Met Gala recently we're
all at the Carlisle no one got inside
it's completely walled off Tara's let me
just um also ask you about the fact that
they were there at all was that Meghan
Markle was receiving this award from
Gloria Steinem for being an inspiring
example of equality and feminism do you
see this
in that way
The Virtue signaling award uh you know
first of all what as the more we talk
about this My Bodyguard instincts just
kicked in and I just have another
question If and I remember there was one
time where me and Snoop were in the
santro page and I mean it was Usher's
birthday party or something with some
craziness and when we came out and we
saw the mob I literally said you know
what we're going back in we're going to
wait out yeah I don't understand why
they would come out of a thing see the
paparazzi coming for them and their
bodyguard wouldn't just say oh we're
going back in because taking them back
in is the safest place to be and then
the ma when you just wait them out or
you get a back entrance so the more I
think about it the more it seems like
especially if if you truly have that
type of fear or a horrible memory the
last thing you would do would be
constantly putting yourself around
cameras that's what I just can't get my
head around it's like why would you go I
can because it's not him yeah we need to
stop blaming him the poor as we would
say and the poor guy he he married a
individual who runs in rampant it's
about her she's receiving an award where
and she's not known for like it's not
like she's going to Calcutta and feeding
orphans she's literally one of the most
selfish people she the the things that
she said about the royal family and the
things that she says about people uh is
not someone that should get an award for
inspiration but again it's virtue
signaling and of course to get more
attention after she received the reward
that none of us even know about the
paparazzi chased him so I mean and now
we're all talking about it so she did
her job and she it just feels like like
I told you every time I look at the poor
guy it looks like he's sitting on a c a
chair of broken glass and he's
constantly being put in the mix I still
say he didn't write that book she did
and he's just caught up and eventually
uh I hope uh that he will stand up for
himself because he seems like a decent
guy yeah I wouldn't go that far um
Charlotte the interesting thing is she
made this speech very gushy typical
making speech but it was all basically
about her feminist credentials it was
about being kind to people it was about
equality is there anything less equal
than being a duchess who uses Royal
titles to make hundreds of millions of
dollars and when it comes to feminism
does she really represent the feminist
icon that young women should look up to
I mean not for me personally to be
honest I think look she was a reasonably
successful actress I sort of don't
necessarily buy the idea that every time
a woman is in the public eye doing
anything that must in some way be a huge
kind of feminist moment and actually I
was thinking listening to that about
Taylor Swift she's lived in North London
for what six years now and she's kind of
a bit I would say responsible at times
in her career for doing the whole I'm a
woman existing therefore that must be
feminist thing too but you never saw any
photos of her because it is possible to
hide if you are a celebrity and if
you've got enough money and no question
I know massive stars you just walk
around Tom Hanks came into a cafe I was
in the New York Upper East actually a
few years ago on his own no body girls
no one bothered him he asked if you
could join me we had the best breakfast
I've ever had but that's New York you
can do that in New York that's the point
um this idea though of Meghan Markle
being an inspiring example of equality
Kevin yeah well is that much equal about
no no and you you know my view on all of
all of that no I mean the they want the
Royal titles the juven Dutchess because
they can monetize it how they make their
their big money I don't know there's no
there's no equality there whatsoever but
I don't think she is entirely bad and I
can see she will inspire some people
perhaps young girls of of color in in
particular uh Tyrus is uh very much
against her I see that but um they could
actually uh hire him as a body card he
sounds like he'd be pretty effective and
there would have been no trouble last
night with him around okay we're gonna
take a short break Taurus I want to uh
if you don't mind staying this for a
little bit Terrors I'd like to talk to
you about this uh story about the
ex-marine who did the choke absolutely I
would love to yeah so stay with us and
we'll talk to you after the break about
that thank you Terrace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
without another story coming out of New
York Jordan Neely a black 30 year old
homeless man born of the Northbound
subway train in New York City on the
afternoon May the 1st what happened next
a shocked and bitterly divided America
because after making threatening
movements and noises saying he was
prepared to kill himself he was then
held in a Chokehold by another passenger
helped by two others the passenger was
the next Marine the footage I have to
warn you is quite distressing
all right
so that went on for several minutes now
Jordan Neely was mentally unwell
schizophrenic it appears he'd been
arrested 42 times before including four
times for assault his killer of course
couldn't have known that by killer I
mean the ex-marine who did the Chokehold
he did end up actually killing Neely who
died in his arms from the Chokehold
after boarding the train originally
nearly had begun shouting so needed food
and money he didn't care if he went to
jail didn't care if he died well the
person that put him in the choker was
Daniel penny a 24 year old ex-marine and
after Jordan nearly died penny has now
been charged with manslaughter and faces
up to 15 years in jail if convicted
besides being obviously shocking the
case is ignited to everything from race
to Justice to out of control urban crime
and the way our society should treat its
most vulnerable people Daniel Penny's
critics so he's a violent vigilante who
killed a mentally ill man his Legions of
supporters lionized him as a hero who
acted to defend fellow passengers more
than 2.6 million has now been donated to
AIDS defense what joining me is a talk
to be contributor Esther cracker black
lives matter organizer activist Iman
ayton the professor of race relations at
the University of Pennsylvania Chad Dion
Lasseter and from New York are still
with uh Tyrus the uh Fox News
contributor and former bodyguard Terrace
let me start with you because it's an
emotive story this uh you know when I
first heard about it I was like okay
this is going to blow really big because
it ticks almost every incendiary box you
could imagine of debate in America right
now do you see this as a a killing or do
you see this as somebody trying to do
the right thing by putting someone you
thought was a threat in a choke hold and
trying to subdue him
Taurus can you hear me
okay Tara's gone heavy all right well
okay let me go to Chad Dion Lester Chad
what do you feel about this story where
do you come at this story from
I think Pierce that it's uh both Ann on
one level we want individuals who are on
subways to be secure to feel safe
whether they're commuting into work
commuting home or just catching a public
transportation the other aspect is the
way that we sometimes have individuals
who engage in white digital anti-ism
with regards to black bodies a lot of
things come to mind for me one this was
a person that was in distress uh this
was a person that was emotionally
unraveling this was a person that uh of
course individuals who were on that
subway platform did not know he had
mental health issues but we need to do a
better job of making sure that our
transit systems have people who are
trained in Mental Health First Aid we
need to also look at the way that we
treat individuals and not making sure
that we making sure that we don't
stigmatize them and so once again we
know that in our democracy here in the
United States a lot of people are going
to be seduced by the black white binary
uh Chokehold is a very dangerous tactic
so for this ex-marine he's trained in
skills and techniques on how to
de-escalate a certain conflicts that may
arise okay we've got Tara's back I think
I mean Taurus I my view of this
um and obviously I want to wait now for
the proper court trial and see what
happens and what emerges but my view is
very hard to say that this ex-marine was
acting malevolently I don't think he
meant to kill
this young man I think he wanted to
subdue him and protect other passengers
from what he thought was a threat
well no it he was a threat and first of
all uh you don't want to see anyone lose
their life that that part uh is is is
tragic but let's not forget uh where
this took place and what's been going on
in the Subways in New York City and a
lot of the Cities across this country
our police departments are defunded
devalued uh our our criminal element is
embolden they understand now that they
can do things uh and they're not going
to be kept in jail that no cash bail
guys are released within the hour uh and
then of course you have the spin
unfortunately the reason why this is
such a big case is the is the worst part
uh have this Marine been a man of color
who was the one had him in the choco we
wouldn't even be having this
conversation right now the two men who
were holding his arms because it was a
fight it was a struggle let's not forget
that let's not forget that ninety
percent of the victims that we see in
the uh in the subway are women and
there's enough videos and I for one was
glad to see men showing up again instead
of holding camera phones and video
recording women getting the life beat
out of them in the in the Subways or
people being shoved and attacked and he
was walking up and down and the subway
basically is a human lunch box there's
not a lot of room in there and he's
walking up and down saying he's going to
hurt he doesn't care if he goes to jail
doesn't care if he hurts someone he's
basically threatening everybody uh and
it wasn't like the Marine was like Hey
I'm going out to attack a person of
color today he was a citizen who've had
enough and okay so was everybody in is
everybody in the subway a co-conspirator
right I mean it's a good question well
let me go to Iman I mean it is an
emotive one nobody wanted this person to
die but nor did those passengers want to
feel threatened by what he was doing
before that and the Marine I think was
trying to do the right thing by
executing something he was able to do
from his training well irrespective of
intent if it your Outlaw your actions
results in death then you should be
charged irrespective of the intent and
the charge will determine the level of
intent so I think it's safe to say
someone died
if you were on a train here we call it
the tube here the subway if you were on
one and somebody got on and was
threatening people and talking about I
don't care if I die and talking about
bullets and so on uh and somebody
stepped in of any color and stepped in
to hold them back and protect you and
other passengers what would you feel
well it comes down to two things I want
to connect kind of connect the two
things firstly he's a Marine he is
trained to kill and he should understand
reasonable force in that instant he
didn't so therefore he needs to be held
to account in terms of vigilanteism for
me personally I believe it's Stepping
Stones to Anarchy so I I I there's
there's a fine line between stepping in
to do the right thing and killings okay
I do think something we have to bear in
mind is this man has been homeless for a
decade he's struggled with mental health
issues he's been in and out of prison
for 42 times he shouldn't have been out
in the public that's that's that's right
that we can proceed on but also I'm also
thinking you know this is someone who's
clearly unhealthy if you if you're
struggling with a mental health
condition and you've been in and out of
prison and you're homeless your physical
Constitution is not as strong as it
would be so there's an argument to say
that while the Marine executed this move
in the way that he knows how he was
probably dealing with someone who was
weaker who was less healthy he might
have used exerted force on someone who
wasn't really built to do that but that
there's that argument because if he's
doing on someone that he thinks is of a
certain status he's a Marine yes
he was warned by another passenger the
Marine he was warned look be careful you
don't kill me you'll be on a charge this
is after about two and a half minutes
and he stopped but he was waiting he
asked him call the police call the
police he was waiting for help to come
to take him so it's just you know I I
don't think it was a deliberate act to
kill this person
the democratic congresswoman she came
out immediately and tweeted this is this
was a public execution
but I thought that was unbelievably
seriously that's different to being
intentional yes but it may have felt
that way to people but there's a
difference between intentions I think
obviously that's irresponsible I do
think what we have to be careful of is
not racializing this because I often say
that when you racialize something like
this you have you know victims of of
black victims in someone like the
southern side of Chicago that are
thinking my black son was killed last
week by a black perpetrator why isn't he
making national news but also this is
not like George Floyd where we all watch
for eight and a half nearly nine minutes
yeah a clearly racially motivated white
police officer snuff a life out of
George Floyd this is a cool official
issue this is a quarter of that time
yeah I just don't I mean we bring Tara's
back in here I just always first of all
right it was very quick as effective as
I can how many people on this panel have
been in a fight how many people in this
panel have actually been in a fight
because I've been in one I've been in
I've been in brawls
without a knife or whatever and if he
was if he was so I don't know if this
issue is whether or not a person has
been in a fight or or not a fight all
these I think there's a lot of things
like people always telling police what
they should do
I think it's more I think it's more
complicated
all right all right yeah
no if I could finish it
let's get a question the Taurus finished
what he said then Chad you respond
because armchair quarting back what
someone does in the moment in a minute
of battle now let's not forget that he
was he had mental issues it also wasn't
just the Marine two other men had to
hold him down while he fight and
struggled which means that one man could
not keep him down again
but let's not sit there and pretend like
that until you've been in a real life
situation where you have to make
split-second decisions then you have the
right to criticize okay Chad you respond
to that okay so so we heard you so so
one the the question of whether or not
people have been in fights or not to me
is insignificant because a lot of us
let me finish let me finish let's let's
have a level of Civility
um there are individuals here where
individuals who are non-violent that's
that's number one
individuals who are non-violent and they
practice non-violence that's number one
number two it doesn't matter what the
data is as it relates to how many times
he could be arrested it could be an
individual that's dressed like me or a
number of us that are on this panel who
could be in distress because of a
trigger because of vicarious
traumatization because of a form of
post-traumatic stress disorder and we're
supposed to know the issue is we need to
make sure that our transportation
centers Mental Health First Aid can help
people with that and once again it's a
structural thing from a structural
standpoint from a macro standpoint we
want people to be safe we want to make
sure that it's not over surveillance of
police uh police state which New York is
we want to be able to have Transit of
people in place and professionals
Community interventionists nurse
practitioners social workers that have
something happens we want to make sure
that we do but the truth is a lot of New
Yorkers the truth is a lot of New
Yorkers do not feel safe on the subway
with good reasons and this well no I
don't think in Philadelphia
people should be able to use the sub
straddling so many uh debate divides I
appreciate it Chad thank you very much I
don't care uh Iman and Esther why don't
you stick around we haven't heard from
you about make it on Harry how do we get
your view about that after the break I
think you probably both got views on
this
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
coming up on the talk Harry and Megan
involved in a two-hour car chase they
say was near catastrophic and Johnny
Depp cried as he received a standing
ovation at the premiere of his comeback
film and just stop oil just won't stop
now they're invading Parliament that's
all at nine
foreign
Paparazzi car chase in Manhattan they
were merely talked to view contributor
Esther cracker and black lives matter
organizer activist Iman ayton okay Iman
what do we make of this
I'm upset for them because these types
of incidences validate your opinion and
others opinions in terms of Harry not
kind of getting over
um the past and incidences that really
resonated I should that's not how I feel
and I said earlier in the show I
actually have I've always had sympathy
with his hatred of Paparazzi given he
blames Paparazzi for killing his mum
right I don't think that's true I think
a drunk driver killed his mum because he
was speeding under an underpass there's
no doubt the paparazzi before and
there's also no doubt because I had
lunch with Diana and William was there
and she talked about the paparazzi how
much it her her how much it hurt him so
I'm under No Illusion about that I just
feel with this the trouble with these
two is they turn everything there's a
phrase I like which is overregged the
souffle right they're always
over-rigging the souffle whatever went
on last night it wasn't a two-hour
high-speed chase around Manhattan it was
probably at least half of that was spent
it seems stationary or in a police
station
um and what was really going on because
it's it's perfectly legal for paparazzi
in New York to follow celebrities that
nobody got arrested the police had said
there was no specific incident nobody
got hurt there was no Collision in the
end it's just Harry and Megan
complaining about press intrusion having
been in an event where they invited the
world's media to come and pay homage to
them but they have the right to complain
about press but we spoke intrusion
During certain incidences in their life
so if they do not have they've still got
the same right to say I don't know if
you think about I have the right to get
into a cab and do whatever I need to do
to avoid them I know but when we first
had this when we first first heard the
story the both of us were like a
two-hour car chase yeah it's like a
two-hour car chase in London you'd end
up in Kent
that's this is that accurate is that
that no it's not accurate they didn't
have a two hour so their statement is
untrue and they say near
catastrophically there was no collision
with anybody nobody got hurt yeah it's
not a catastrophe it's not a near
catastrophe what it is is them being
pursued by Paparazzi people may have a
view watching this about Paparazzi
should never do that I think the
paparazzi are part of the oxygen of
celebrity and if you caught the Medias
aggressively and as thirstly as these
two have done you are going to get a lot
of Paparazzi attention well I mean I
felt bad because initially I just my
immediate reaction was was sadness
obviously but also doubt because the
two-hour car chase in Manhattan didn't
but it's not true and that's in their
statements you know half of that
immediately is not true at the same time
can they where do they draw the line
because if you're going to complain
about media intrusion you've intruded
into your own life so much where do you
draw the line and I think that's what I
really struggle with I feel like these
are people that especially with Regatta
Harry they are troubled they are
genuinely troubled I think that's right
and I think about here's the thing with
them that they constantly suing
obviously I'm involved in a case at the
moment with the the mirror uh which I
can't talk about until it's over so I
won't talk about it but there are lots
of battles there's like six lawsuits all
at the moment with Harry suing all the
media right and it seems to me that they
just occasionally they do a book
invading their privacy over 400 pages to
do a Netflix seriously and then in
between they're raging about media
intrusion yeah and I'm not sure the
public I'm not sure the public are
wearing that anymore and I I appreciate
that point clearly I was one that that
definitely supported them I don't in the
same way that I initially did so you're
right on that point but I can happily
say that I don't actually think that
they are conflating the two things I
think try privacy is one thing and
defending yourself is another and so if
you write a book and you're trying to
defend your name you're trying to defend
all the stories that have written about
you that's one thing and then making
sure that you have privacy when you're
on your way to the shop that's two
seconds
I remember when Diana died and in the
aftermath everyone hated the paparazzi
and I remember there was it was a
premier in London I think it was George
Clooney I don't want to speak out a turn
about it if it wasn't but I think it was
George Clooney and he came out and he'd
been very disparaging about Paparazzi
and he came out and all the paparazzi
turned their banks on him
oh yeah and it was a real moment where
actually a major celebrity major
celebrity went wow hang on what happened
what happened to the oxygen of publicity
for what I want my premieres mother what
if that disappears well yeah
whether they like each other or not
they're all part of the same celebrity
part system and Netflix wouldn't have
been paying them 100 million dollars if
it wasn't for the paparazzi it wasn't
for the noise that they've created
around them so he had an opportunity to
defend himself and therefore he was paid
as a result so because I think defense
you have to again you have to draw the
line somewhere I agree
defending yourself is not Oprah and then
a series
I'd actually contest you on that point
the first opportunity for him to defend
himself he I I think I don't want to put
words into their mouth but they would
arguably say it was Oprah and then the
kind of second the Netflix where we had
the kind of I don't know
they decided we've got it we've got to
leave we've got to leave it here but I
think that's right think about them is
nobody should be subjected to the way
they've categorized what happened last
night the issue is have they categorized
it accurately correctly if there were
Paparazzi bombing down the Pavements so
you know endangering people uh at 80
miles an hour that's one thing if that
didn't happen and they've oversold it
again then that's a different issue I
think we'll find out we'll probably see
some videos thank you suppose if you
appreciate it whatever you're up to keep
it unsensitive good night
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]